-Let's get to the news.
According to a new report,
President Biden is ready
to help lobby moderate Democrats
to support reforming
the filibuster
and told Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer,
"Tell me when you need me
to start making phone calls."
Said Schumer,
"You haven't even started
making calls?!"
During a speech on Thursday
outlining his new plan
to fight the coronavirus,
President Biden
scolded travelers
who refuse to wear masks
on airplanes.
Great. Now do shoes.
During a September 11th
memorial dinner on Saturday,
Rudy Giuliani imitated
Britain's Queen Elizabeth
by marrying his cousin.
[ Laughter ]
Supreme Court Justice
Amy Coney Barrett
appeared yesterday at an event
with Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
and said she was worried
that the public sees the court
as a partisan institution,
which is kind of like performing
at the VMAs with Taylor Swift
and worrying that people will
see you as a musician.
The MTV Music Awards --
Video Music Awards were held
last night, and Madonna made
a surprise appearance
to open the show.
The audience was so shocked,
they all got out their phones
and looked her up on Wikipedia.
I know. They're young.
I know.
The fast food chain Burger King
last week unveiled
its so-called Keep It Real Meal,
which partners with
several celebrities,
but uses their real names
instead of stage names.
Though I'm not sure how well
the Robert Allen Zimmerman
burger will sell.
[ Laughter ]
An investigation concluded
last week
that a recent MTA subway outage
that shut down 83 trains
was caused by someone
accidentally flipping
a power switch.
Said one man,
"So that's what it does!"
And finally,
Facebook has collaborated
with the eyewear brand Ray-Ban
to release new sunglasses
that can take pictures, make
phone calls, and play music.
On the downside,
you're currently
sitting on them.
♪♪
Secretary of State Tony Blinken
testified today before the
Senate Foreign Affairs Committee
about the U.S. withdrawal
from Afghanistan,
but not before trying
every other topic first.
"Okay, before we get to that,
who wants to hear what's
in Area 51?"
After former President
George W. Bush appeared
to compare Capitol rioters
to foreign terrorists
in a speech commemorating
the September 11th attacks,
former President Trump
said yesterday that Bush
"shouldn't be
lecturing anybody."
And I never thought
I'd say this sentence, but,
Bush, Trump,
you're both right.
The U.S. will host
a virtual summit
with global leaders next week
called Global COVID-19 Summit:
Ending the Pandemic
and Building Back Better.
In related news,
the Mets are hosting a seminar
at the Hyatt Regency called
How to Win the World Series.
[ Laughter ]
Russian President Vladimir Putin
is reportedly self-isolating
after several members
of his entourage
tested positive
for the coronavirus.
And they must have
some new variant over there
because one of the symptoms is
falling off a balcony.
[ Laughter ]
A group of Senate Democrats
introduced
new voting rights
legislation today
which would make Election Day
a public holiday
and require same-day
voter registration,
while Senate Republicans
introduced legislations
that you have to have
six forms of ID,
be able to beat the underwater
levels in "Mario,"
and reunuite Oasis.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Senate Democrats
introduced a new
voting rights bill
which would make Election Day
a public holiday.
But not for you, Kornacki!
24 straight hours on your feet.
No bathroom breaks for Kornacki!
House Democrats yesterday
proposed new tax increases
on corporations,
the wealthy, investors,
and high-income business owners.
And this is weird --
they announced it
on AOC's dress.
After she announced
that she has not received
the coronavirus vaccine,
rapper Nicki Minaj
tweeted yesterday
that a friend of her cousin
received the shot
and became impotent after
"his testicles became swollen."
Which is pretty shocking because
when I got the shot,
it was in my arm.
[ Laughter ]
A new study suggests that cows
can be potty trained
as easily as toddlers.
"Then I know
what the problem is,"
said your plumber.
[ Laughter ]
"It's, uh,
it's cow [bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the annual Met Gala
was last night,
an event known for
the over-the-top,
avant garde outfits worn by its
celebrity guests.
Now, to everyday people,
those outfits might just look
like a collection
of crazy styles,
but in the fashion industry,
every style actually has a name.
For example,
you might call my style
"wine dad"
or "guy who listens
to three podcasts."
Well, we want to take a look now
at some of the most
exciting looks
from last night's Met Gala
and let you in on their official
industry names.
So, here's the first one.
We have J.Lo.
Here's what she wore.
And this look is called the...
That's what they call it.
These aren't my names.
Kim Kardashian was
at the Met Gala last night.
Let's see what she wore.
It's called...
They also kicked around
Lookin' Sharpie.
or Kim's Actually at Home
Watching Netflix.
Dan Levy was there.
He was also there.
This is the...
They also considered
calling it
That Dinosaur
That Killed Newman.
There's a lot of crossover
between people who are
super into fashion
and who have granular knowledge
of "Seinfeld."
Ben Platt --
Or Boogie School Nights.
Rihanna was there
looking flawless as ever
with her looked called...
Next up, we have K-pop star CL.
That's who Shoemaker was
most excited about.
[ Laughing ] We also...
I like this one.
The alt for CL was [bleep]
I Forgot I Ordered Room Service!
[ Laughter ]
Kim Petras with her...
Dressaged to the Nine.
Nines.
That's why there was no laugh.
[ Laughter ]
See?
Threw the "nines" on it,
fixed it.
[ Laughter ]
Lil Nas X --
CPO -- C3P-Oh Snap!
C3P-Oh Snap.
Last one up, you guys --
A$AP Rocky.
Also would have accepted
A Nap Rocky?
[ Laughter ]
Or not accepted it.
Though the important thing
is I'm just glass --
[ Laughs ]
The important thing is
I'm just glad it was last.
[ Laughter ]
You want to close on the one
that just makes
everybody go, "Ehh."
♪♪
California Governor Gavin Newsom
yesterday
defeated a recall attempt
by a nearly 2:1 margin,
and Newsom was so relieved,
his hair unclenched.
[ Laughter ]
After former
Vice President Mike Pence
told former President Trump
during a meeting on January 5th
that he didn't have the power
to overturn the 2020 election,
Trump reportedly said,
"But wouldn't it be almost cool
to have that power?"
You're asking Mike Pence
what's cool?
[ As Pence ] Well, yeah,
I guess that would be cool,
but then again,
so is "Godspell."
[ Normal voice ]
According to a new book,
Joint Chiefs of Staff
Chairman General Mark Milley
took steps
after January's Capitol attack
to limit former
President Trump's ability
to launch a nuclear strike.
Specifically,
he changed the launch code
to 11112.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new book,
President Biden finds living
at the White House
to be cold and lonely.
Said the decorator,
"Thank you!"
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
more than half of Americans said
that they have never been
in a physical fight.
"But what if someone
slightly inconveniences you?"
asked Boston.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a man in England
recently claimed
he had a McDonald's sandwich
with a pig nipple in it.
Even more disturbing,
it was a Filet-O-Fish.
[ Laughter ]
Hard to get more disturbing,
but Goldich found
that extra gear.
♪♪
Following reports
that Joint Chiefs of Staff
Chairman General Mark Milley
took steps to limit
former President Trump's ability
to order military actions,
White House press secretary
Jen Psaki defended Milley
and said, "It's important to
consider some of the context."
Okay, let's do that.
-♪ Bing, bing, bong, bong,
bing, bing, bing ♪
-He did the right thing.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden met virtually
yesterday
with British Prime Minister
Boris Johnson
and Australian Prime Minister
Scott Morrison
and, of course,
Morrison's translator.
"Oy, mate, how ya goin'?"
He says,
"It's nice to meet you."
Ahead of the Justice for J6
rally on Saturday
in support of
the Capitol rioters,
Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham told reporters,
"If anybody gets out of line,
they need to whack them."
That's pretty tough talk
for someone
who definitely calls the police
on spiders.
"I flushed him,
but he's crawling back up.
Hurry!"
[ Laughter ]
After she tweeted this week
that she has not received
the coronavirus vaccine
and had heard of a man
who became impotent from it,
rapper Nicki Minaj
said yesterday that she had been
invited to the White House.
This escalated
to the White House?
Nicki, did you ever think
maybe this guy
doesn't want his balls
to be trending so much?
"Hey, man, did you ever
text your cousin
and ask her to stop talking
about my nuts?"
"I did, but her phone was off
'cause she's meeting
with the president about them."
[ Laughter ]
Dr. Anthony Fauci said
in a new interview
that there's
no scientific evidence
to support rapper
Nicki Minaj's claim
that a friend of her cousin
is impotent
after his testicles
became swollen
from receiving
the coronavirus vaccine.
And going forward, Dr. Fauci
encourages all Americans
to take pause
when someone starts a story
with "a friend of my cousin."
House Democrats yesterday
proposed a tax hike
on tobacco and
nicotine products.
In related news,
Mary-Kate and Ashley
have breached the Capitol.
The National Toy Hall of Fame
has announced
that their 12 finalists
for the 2021 induction
include American Girl dolls,
the board game Battleship,
and sand.
I'm sorry, sand?
What kind of freak kid asks
their parents for sand?
Imagine Christmas being ruined
because the only thing
in your kid's PlayStation box
was a PlayStation.
"I specifically asked for sand!"
A British man was recently
arrested in the Netherlands
and brought to the Hague --
I'm sorry, sand?!
I guess I'm not ready
to move on.
You're inducting sand into
the National Toy Hall of Fame.
Was gravel not available?
[ Laughter ]
"Wow! So many people to thank.
First and foremost, erosion."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a burglar in Ohio
was arrested this week
after he allegedly
broke into a home,
ate chicken dinner leftovers,
swam in a pool,
lit a candle in the bathroom,
and then fell asleep
in a guest bedroom.
The man has been charged
with one count of
having a lovely evening.
♪♪